museum's reporting vietnam exhibit
get our complete schedule at cspan.org
70 years ago in 1945 allied forces
liberated the nazi concentration camps
on american history tv will hear
holocaust stories from those who live
them
these interviews are part of the oral
history collection at the united states
holocaust memorial museum in washington
dc
up next u.s army veteran john holmes
talks about his reactions to coming
across a nazi labor camp in the hearts
region of austria and liberating the
jews who were imprisoned there
he also remembers some of his regiment's
encounters with nazi soldiers throughout
the war mr holmes died in 2013.
this oral history is about 30 minutes
we were fighting in the hearts mountain
sector
um
on our way into fighting in austria
anyway
when we when we when we ca when we
crossed
this river
and we came into this um
area the germans were in there
but they were more they didn't they
didn't put up any resistance
and they had um an airport nearby
and as a matter of fact this was the
place i saw my first german jets
and i never knew what they were
but i knew they were just damn fast
because i tried to open up fire on a
couple of them
and by the time you could get your guns
trained
the thing was
going like that
but anyway um we uh we passed this house
and off in the distance
you could see huge warehouses and then
long rows of um
something like a i don't know it's not a
quonset hut but
it's a square long buildings
and and it had a gate in it
and i don't recall what the writing was
up over the gate but
what it what we did encounter
inside of there
i got out of the turn of my tank
and walked in
to see what was inside
and that was when i did
you could smell
death for maybe 20 miles before you ever
got to it because it's very different
humans
and animals
entirely different
you can stand a cow or a horse or
something that's been shot up but a
human being is
that's the stench of death from it is
it's it's awful
so
i saw this
high ceiling
and this little
narrow pathway down the center and it
had maybe
12 or 14 tears
and and there's just enough room maybe
oh i'd say
for individual
to slip through
between each
tier of bunks
and can you imagine them being twi not
me at six foot it is
twice as high
as i am told
in other words you got 12 or 14 feet
of these bunks they got little ladders
going up there and these people now you
might find underneath here would be a
dead person
and then
living in that
living person was just too damn weak to
even move
and all the elderly just hold out their
hand
and you were afraid to touch them
some of them had
scabs and swords and everything on them
they had just been there for and and
what i understand that these people
were fed
ounce
of meat i think was once a week
they were also
given a potato soup
or cabbage soup
once a day
and a small cube of bread
might have been about like so
and i don't know how thick it was but it
couldn't have been very thick but that's
all they were that's all they were given
and they were nothing they had an
american kernel in there
i don't know how many months he had been
a prisoner
but
he originally weighed about two
his height must have been i'd say good
six four
he originally weighed about 230 maybe a
little bit more
and i don't think that he weighed any
more than 80 pounds
when we saw him
so you can imagine the
the horror that those people suffered
under german occupation
um
as prisoners of war they didn't even
feed some of them
they
it was just
i i i the only thing that i can say that
you would have to have seen it the
pictures that you saw
depicting the death in the concentration
camps this was identically the same
when you first drove the tank in did you
did you drive right in no no no i don't
drive you know i was tank commander my
driver didn't
tell me were there any people outside
none at all
and did you exchange fire with anyone or
everyone was gone the germans took off
and left everything just as it was
even their warehouses of guns this this
was the the um i think this was the um
the walter
32
they made a 32 pistol
and these
uh these uh prisoners that were capable
of work any work at all
were the
laborers that did the assembling
of these pistols and all in that in that
big huge factory to the rear
there was no other gun there but that
and they had them in there by the
hundreds
just cases of them
you kind of like wonder what
went all that trouble to make those guns
and could have been feeding some of
those people
so when you went in the barracks and you
found all this did you could you talk to
anyone
tell me what else happened with them it
was it was virtually can you can can you
imagine trying to talk someone to
someone that do they don't even have the
strength
for their vocal cords to even operate
we were warned
not to give them anything like our
c-rations and our k-rations don't give
them that
see these people had to be fed
a broth
something that was soupy that they could
swallow that would not choke them to
death because if you fed them they
couldn't swallow it if you gave them
solid food because a lot of people made
that mistake a lot of our soldiers made
that mistake when they
ran across where
they had
you know liberated somebody that had
been under starvation conditions
and they gave them their food
the food has a tendency to choke you
then
and you just choke to death
whereas it's able to just let them alone
and let the people gradually eat
soup
until
they get the strength back to where
your stomach becomes acclimated to it
were you surprised
yes i was i i truly was because i just
couldn't
believe
that
an individual
that
that is supposed to be fighting
for the preservation of his
culture and his country
could be doing this to
people that had no
defense
i couldn't believe this
because you you're flabbergasted
you you you're so shocked by what you're
looking at well i'll give you a good
example
i i
i i wasn't really surprised yet i was i
can say this
the 14th recons
platoon was out scouting
and they ran into a bunch of noxi ss
and they were captured and we had a hell
of a fire fight
and
i i definitely was responsible
for killing
one
two three four
i'd say approximately
six
german soldiers myself
directing fire in on them
they these they they captured about
a dozen
of these uh it was a 14th continents
reconnaissance unit
and they tied their hands behind their
back and they tied their feet together
and i'm not telling you what somebody
told me i'm telling you what exactly i
saw
and in this little town there must have
been at least
no i don't even think this town had a uh
six houses in it
but it had a little road that went down
like and did you know those noxi ss
sobs took those those those young boys
we're all about the same age
and they
when they put when they tied their hands
and feet together hands behind their
back and they laid them out along the
road
in a row and they put a bullet right
between their eyes
and i can recall
from this firefight headquarters company
i think came in from the
southeast
and they had 105
guns 105 millimeter guns
ours was was 75 and 76
millimeters we killed just i think we
killed all of them
i don't recall us taking any prisoners
because you had to kill them because
they were not going to surrender
the nazi ss was not going to surrender
they would shoot and shoot until they
were killed it was stupid because they
were raised all the way from the hitler
youth
and that's what they believed in
and when you called me they all had that
insignia on their collar
so that's how you knew what you were
fighting
when you were first coming in was there
an exchange of fire and you shot down a
plane
no
there was no exchange of fire period the
only thing that um because we were
really amazed to see these um
this
this junkers
i think what would say
one
a junk it wasn't a junk it was it was a
german transport
well the one that i opened fire up on
was um
a transport i think it had high ranking
uh german officers in it
and of course we never saw it crash
because when we shot into it
you know by the time when it's
approaching you
and you open fire with 50 caliber
machine guns
um
you don't know how many slugs
you put in them but um or
who survived what with the plane
you really you're two or three thousand
feet off the ground and it just go it's
going on in and and the engines are
smoking you know it's gonna crash but it
crashed way back
to the back of us so we never got a
chance to see what you know damage
you've done
and were there guards in the guard
houses when you came to this none at all
absolutely hey i told you everybody
they just
they say they shag tail on out of there
uh whatever whatever guns and everything
they had they just dropped them and ran
now they didn't want to come number one
um
the the german soldier
was told all the way back from
world war one
when they had black americans fighting
over there in europe
that
don't be captured by black troops
because it would cut your throat
of course which was a lie
but during world war one a lot of our
guys did do that
they would infiltrate into the german
lines at night
in world war one and they had razors
and they don't nobody know when somebody
you know slap their hand across your
mouth and then cut your throat and you
lay them bleed to death and the rest of
the guys around you that that survived
it didn't even know
that you were dead particularly the
sentries on the outer line parts
they were always caught off guard and
killed like that
but
this went all the way back
this
they said
as a matter of fact the german soldiers
were we shot up i don't know whether you
saw um liberators fighting on two front
this one particular guy was in my outfit
um
there was a bunch of germans must have
been two or three thousand that came out
in the woods
and
german soldiers and they came out
and they took a look and they looked and
saw the black soldiers and
and they said
what oh no not you guys and they turned
around and started back through the
woods and we put some high explosives
over their head and they come on back
out just as nice with their hands on
backup season
they would rather take a chance rather
than me blowing the bits
uh come on out and then let's talk
turkey
when you went into this camp that you
came upon
about how long did you stay
oh
i would imagine we must have been there
at least
inside the camp itself maybe about an
hour
hour an
hour and a half
and
when it came orders to move out
i had already talked to this lady mrs
schimel
because she came to the door
and
she flagged me down and she said um
soldier she said um
her english was very good
mrs schimel
you would have thought that she was
from the states
but she was ready she was an austrian
person
of german decent and so she asked me who
i was from i said i said i'm from
chicago
she said
sergeant she said you're from chicago i
said yeah she's you know where skokie is
i said sure i know where skokie is
this is right across the canal from
where my mother lives
she's i have a sister there
and i wonder if you would give her a
letter for me
and i said well sure so i gave her she
wrote the letter and i
when i was discharged i took it by the
house and gave it to her
and we of course we didn't stay in the
communications with one another after
that because her husband was rather
nasty and i didn't i didn't want to be
bothered with him
going back
but
she was pretty
but the woman herself was very nice
met the sister and she thanked me
for delivering that and all
and i think the sister in skokie
wound up sending for her and she she's
still living she's in the states now
well
do you know what happened to those the
people in the camp after you left no
no
no they didn't have you been told what
to expect had you been talking nope
but you had been told not to
feed
only after we had
secured the camp
and who taught tell me more about that
how did you get the word
we got it from uh our battalion
commander
or one of our officers
because i can't recall whether it was a
major or a captain
that said do not give them anything the
word was passed down all the way down
the line do not feed these prisoners
under any circumstances
because
they wanted as many of them alive as
possible
because see they all had a story to tell
also
where they were captured
and how long what concentration camp
they came from because a lot of
instances see like bergen belts and all
of those places like that when they
if
they needed
workers
and didn't have enough that in one
sector they would send them from on a
train
box cars full of them
all the way down to
another sector to fill out as a
workforce those that they could trust
what did the people when you went into
these barracks with these tall
benches
for the people what did the people do to
you i mean how did they react
they they couldn't those that were
living all they
they looked like death eating a soda
cracker
that's what we used to call it they they
were like they were skinning skin and
bones
you
can you imagine a skeleton trying to
talk to you
and holding out his hand
can you imagine that
you get any kind of inkling what it's
like
and this is all you saw
these people
could not get up
these people were literally abandoned
and i
imagine
that
when the germans took off
running
i imagine
that those that were capable of going
they herded them in front of them
because see
upon our approach
the germans were not going to stick
around
they were not going to stick around to
for us to see them nor how many
prisoners they took with them
and whether they killed them or not i do
not know but you know the orders were
from adolf hitler
was to that
any prisoners that when the americans
approached kill all the prisoners
that was
what about
what about any revenge against the
germans because of this do you think any
of that did it instill anger and
no it didn't distill it didn't instill
anger because you know so number one
i think the shock of something like that
could i explain something
if you're fighting a german soldier and
you kill him
that that happens
you look down at him and that's and you
keep right on moving
that's an individual that's trying to
kill you and it doesn't but when you see
something where
here is uh
here are individuals by the
dozens that have done nothing to no one
but
for their their their their captors said
do this or do that and you did it
this is the you were so shocked by this
looking at it that i don't i think the
the the shock of something like that
does not wear off right away
so therefore you can't uh you can't
you you just can't
i just don't know how to i wish i could
phrase it
because i can still see it
i'm as i'm talking to you now i can see
the whole horrible picture
and it's not nice
so do you know if
there was any
message to bring help to those people
oh yes
our commanding officer
see we had radios in the tanks
and
we had our half tracks that had
communication to divisions
and the divisions in turn would get the
medics up there
and they
the medics would come in and they would
load these prisoners
onto
two and a half ton trucks
by the dozens
and they they would take them back to
the rear to the hospitals and they
worked with them until
over three or four months six months
they would get this strength back to
where they could walk around
but when you could just look at them
some of them had swords the size of your
hands on them
where they had been laying there for
weeks
i want you to tell me what kind of
impact this
had on you
the impact that it had on me was the
fact that uh
i i
i never quite understood it
uh it is hard to
war is uh i think one of the one of the
worst things that has ever happened to
this country is that it never
got a chance to fight on its own soil
against a formidable enemy
it's always gone out done the fighting
on that enemy soil
if
the
people in this country
could actually see what total war is all
about
in reality they would have a different
perspective
on everything that's around them i think
they would have a little more compassion
toward one another
because when you have
a race of people
who
think that they are superior to
everybody else
and everybody else is dirt underneath
their feet
you're going to have
the same thing because one of the things
that history says is always if you don't
remember the mistakes in the past you're
going to repeat it all over again
this is something this this episode over
in germany and france and belgium and
holland and luxembourg that where i
fought in
i just couldn't believe that the enemy
could be as cruel and brutal as he was
and the thing about it
the german
many of the germans right today don't do
not believe that this actually happened
that these they don't believe that the
holocaust
and the young i i um spoke
the university of portland and
university of seattle and they
so many of the children the students out
there did not believe that the holocaust
really happened
they thought it was just a figment of a
nation
you know my imagination
and i said look i said this is a black
man talking to you i said this is you're
not talking to a white man i'm talking
what i fought in and what i saw i said
i'm not you i don't have to ask nobody
what i went through and what i saw
tell me more about the condition of
those people that you saw were they
still people
i mean what what was it that did
what is it that brings you
what is it that's so devastating about
that scene other than
seeing the enemy who was trying to kill
you who you have killed
what
what about it
those
people that like i said before those
people could not help themselves
they had no help from no one
they were between a rock and a hard
place
you've got to do what you're told the
best thing that ever happened uh to what
some of them did for us uh which i
thought was them was amazing
is that they sabotaged a lot of the
german
shells and what have you
because one of the one on our way
through the hearts mountain i can
remember that when the germans dropped
some mortars in on us and not a single
one explode
they didn't explode at all
only to be found at later on that there
was no fuse to set them off
they just left the fuses out of them
the shells
and you make a connection between those
people that you found in that
yes
they say
in other words
they actually saved a lot of american
lives
absolutely by
diffusing a lot of the german artillery
shells and mortar shells
because
at the darnedest thing that this when we
cross the
it's a rhine i think it's a rhino the
daniel i know which one it was in the
south down
we crossed this big river on the
pontoons and that was a horrible thing i
think i would have died a thousand
deaths you're going to cross this river
and it's like this and you've got about
three or four hundred
feet going across the room the thing is
like this and you've got a 36 ton tank
that's bobbing up and down it's kind of
worse but when you got to the other side
and
we're in the middle of this town and we
had just
got out i just got out of the turn in my
tank and we were kind of guys you need
to stretch your legs a little bit
there's no artillery fire around the
germans are way up in the high ground
away from you now
so they decided germans decided to drop
a few mortars in on us
and the darnest thing i ever saw in my
life three of them fell right in the
midst of us
not a single one
exploded go go back and tell me again
about the people that you found there
just just death really
they were walking dead far as i could
see
living dead
i do not know how many
of those people in those barracks were
dead but i do know this that there were
many of them
because you could see them
when you see
when you when you don't see any ribs
going up and down as you're breathing
and you look down and you and and you
can smell that too
you know they're dead
and those that are laying there and
they're trying to stretch their hand out
to you and they can't talk
because they don't have the strength
and not i don't i do not remember anyone
but that american colonel
being helped up
and he had to be helped up and helped to
move one leg in front of the other
this is how
this is how bad it was
in other words he was they had two two
soldiers one with his arm
around holding him up and the other one
on the other side holding him up and he
and his feet were actually dragging
basically
all the other than that all the rest of
them i was still back in those in in
those bunks
this was
this is the site i i've never forgotten
that
and what about it what what what what
one amazing thing to me with mrs schimel
mr schamel did not know all of this was
going on
because this was just about i'd say
three quarters of a mile back of her
but i imagine though by her being jewish
she she was actually hidden
she assumed the identity of the people
that she that that protected her there's
a lot of good german people now
i think some of the german people knew
what was happening
but she didn't see it
because she didn't know what that all of
this death and destruction was going on
back of her
she could smell it but she didn't know
what it was
for she was concerned it was some of the
bloated animals out there
and not being acclimated to the smell of
humans and animals too i imagine she
just assumed that it was all just one
thing
so this
that's all i can attribute to with her
she
she was just an innocent bystander
and i was often i was i kept thinking i
said now
first of all she said to me i asked her
i said mr shaman i said how is it that
you
survived this
and she explained to me she said well
they protected me
and she i think she had assumed their
name
that that's probably what saved her
and whether she blended in with the
family or
or what
but this house was slightly isolated
from the rest of the town
so
that perhaps is what saved her that
experience of opening that camp have
more of an impact on you than
just the whole general combat experience
oh yes it uh um
see because number one when you're
fighting and you're killing you can do
that
with impunity you don't forget this
thing
number one you have an enemy to kill
or else you're gonna die you got one or
two choices
but when you see this
and you and they can't do nothing about
what's happening to them
sure you're not gonna forget it
you never will
it's impossible to forget something like
that
um
i forget the name of the camp down
around munich
is that
no
it's not auschwitz
dachau that's the one
we had a lieutenant uh
in the outfit that was at
that cam
but he just happened to him he he was uh
his tank his column of tanks were
were moving through and he asked
the soldiers what was going on inside
there
and that that was when
that was the only time i ever heard of a
concentration camp was when he said that
that was a duck cow
but like i said i never knew what a
concentration camp was
i didn't even know what a labor camp was
because what i was the only thing that
we didn't see we never had we never had
the opportunity because they were
constantly on on the move and you and
and you're shooting and fighting at the
same time in wisconsin we had 183 days
of combat
and it was just constantly go go go into
to
to run into a situation like this was
just
it wasn't it was phenomenal to me i just
didn't believe anything like that
existed